hello bill my name is Peter I live in
Miami and my question has to do with the
sense of humor it seems logical that the
sense of humor is a sign of higher
intelligence mainly because it usually
involves more than one person and so my
question is is there any evidence that
any other animal other than man has a
sense of humor thanks Peter Peter in
Miami greetings a sense of humor since
humor inherent I think so it seems to me
I've watched chimpanzees have fun with
each other just watching them I think
Gibbons have fun I think they do things
for fun and I will definitely say this
there's a some famous pictures of
penguins climbing up the ice hill and
sliding down on their penguin tummies to
go headfirst into the what you and I
would think really cold water but they
dig it apparently and they're I cannot
think of any evolutionary reason for
that except it just looks like they're
having fun
and so to me fun and a sense of humor
intimately connected now I will say
something about evolution and sense of
humor what you want if you're trying to
attract a mate I think a sense of humor
is very important I think if you're
funny if you're engaging if you have a
good smile especially you're more
attractive to the opposite sex so
there's huge selection pressure to have
a sense of humor among humans and I I
guess I should say something funny here
something funny haha there I said it
see so I think sense of humor is deep
within us and if it starts with penguins
I mean they're dinosaurs literally in
modern cladistics and modern reckoning
it must go way back just as an observer
of the primate condition and have the
dinosaur ax condition
I think sense of humor is is deep within
us how would we test for that if you had
a hypothesis like that how would you
test to see if have a sense of humor you
know where I would start I don't know if
you've ever been around babies I was a
baby myself for a while there is nothing
that brings greater joy than
hide-and-seek peekaboo I wonder if
primate babies are into peekaboo and I
say all the time the greatest toy yet
invented is the jack-in-the-box where
you turn the crank and there's a little
music and then the jack-in-the-box jumps
out and you never know when he's going
to do it and every time it happens it's
so exciting and it's some levels so
funny for some reason I guess because
you're asking yourself why would Jack
get in this box and what did I do to
make him jump out whatever it is it's
really funny when you're of a certain
age so I would test a jack-in-the-box on
primates I wonder how many papers have
been written about such things it's an
excellent question Peter thank you carry
on in Miami
[Music]